and your book closes on what I think is
the most powerful important message I've
seen in quite some time
um which is Christians can and should
become agents of nuance rather than of
reductionism and I was like wow is that
powerful uh this means embracing
complexity and rejecting easy
explanations there's a journalist named
Amanda Ripley who wrote a book called
high conflict
um I hope I'm getting that right I think
that's correct
and I I think the book came out of an
essay she wrote called complicating the
narrative
we live in a time where
there is so much information
there's so much entertainment
there's so much stress and busyness and
so we're all dealing with a need to
simplify
and so that is the the pressure that
adds on top of the natural human
instinct to reduce things to you know
understandable terms understandable
Concepts
so I understand the instinct to reduce
and simplify
but when it comes to
issues of disagreement especially
we have to resist that instinct because
once we oversimplify and reduce things
then those who disagree with us are
caricatured and demonized into just bad
people yep it's and it's never that
simple almost ever I mean I I I want to
say never but there probably are some
situations where you know the person we
disagree with or the or the bad person
really is just mostly bad but most of
the time like people are coming from
their point of view and they think they
have good motives and good reasons for
what they're doing and
um I I think a Christian's duty is to
bring healing to the world and to be the
hands and feet of Christ and to bring
love uh to our to our neighbor to love
our neighbor as Christ told us and I
think do a big part of that is
complicating The Narrative resisting
those easy answers because I think
that's a big part of loving our neighbor
hey YouTube glad you're enjoying the
podcast if you really like it hit
subscribe and then YouTube will notify
you every time we have a bang-up new
guest thank you